Chris you're joining us you don't want
to do like summer league overreactions
then we can do that everybody just just
as giddy about Kevin Knox Kevin Knox
some new Carmelo to lead New York to the
next level yeah we can do that we we had
people over reacting last week to Kevin
Knox who do you think is the biggest
overreaction to who aside from Knox who
would you put up there I mean I don't
want to call an overreaction yet because
I think he's good but I mean Collin
Sexton is like the heir apparent to
LeBron at this point out in Vegas um you
know one of the most impressive at
Summer League if if that means anything
but I've seen you listen to people that
are following Cleveland that's like oh
no not that we don't need LeBron but
this is going to be the guys like it's
like they got Kyrie here after losing
LeBron you know seven eight years ago
I like Josh Hart with what he did I
don't know if I'm overreacting to it but
the fact that he said he wanted Ali in
the summer way you are no I am yeah man
amongst boys they're a little bit like
he's not only was he a four-year college
player but he had a year of the crows
and he's kind of you got writing a story
for tomorrow dan unlike the the boys of
summer kind of the summer league legends
that are out there the Jack Cooley's of
the world the Scott Machado's of the
world like these guys have just been
been there forever why are you still
you're a buzzkill Mannix why I just I
just want to see well first of all I'm I
literally have a calendar marking out
the days of my hair leaves and and now
I'm just waiting for this whole summer
bill NBA season to sort of wind down
okay wait you come in to get your hair
shaved off at the end of July right July
30th July 30th mannix in the studio are
you bringing in somebody to cut your
hair or should I get somebody one 100%
I'm bringing somebody in okay I should
have approval there has to be security
clearance approval to you you can do
that
but I have approval on what is it the
attachment that they use to go far down
like you're not taking a blade to my ex
I know we're not doing that I'm selling
no we're not doing that yeah no no no I
want you to attack order didn't cry
didn't cross your mind at all didn't
cross your mind at all really we have a
mock up right now if you're watching on
TV now you look like Jeff Van Gundy bald
yeah you know yeah that's that's that's
not a great lighting looks hot yeah
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
look great be LeBron frenzy what did you
make of it I mean not unexpected I mean
if you remember was it last year he
showed up at a lake or some early game
and everybody kind of like said he was
scouting Alonzo ball and and all that so
he's done this you know he pops into
summer league to watch and and and this
was was expected him coming in there I
mean I don't know what you gain out of
it if you're if you're LeBron James and
yeah you can look at at Josh Hart the
Lakers have a couple of young players
that are probably going to make the
roster this year but you know what when
you talk to people in and around the
Lakers they don't really have any kind
of of offense yet like they don't really
know I mean they have an idea of what
they want to do but there's nothing kind
of set in stone they're just a long way
to go Dan before we start the season to
the Lakers to kind of figure out how
they're gonna play around LeBron James
all right you made some headlines where
you said that this this roster is
combustible that you know with the guys
that they brought in with just trying to
mix this all in one pot did you still
feel that way absolutely and you know I
you know and a lot of the stuff I think
on my own but you know you I spend the
entire week last week in Vegas talking
to coaches about that mix and the vast
majority of them agree with me I mean
it's yeah I don't even know how you know
combustible with this group is even a
hot take at this point I mean you've got
you know Lance Stephenson who is like
you know the personification of
combustible you've got you know Rondo la
zone Lavar situation which is as
combustible as as it gets
you throw in LeBron and you know being
very unclear at this point about which
these young players he really wants to
play with long term and a coach and Luke
Walton who has to prove himself like
everybody I mean I think Luke Walton is
still proving himself to magic and to
rob polenka guys that didn't hire him
and clearly is gonna prove himself to
LeBron who is gonna have his own ideas
tsukushi coached the team so I don't
know this is gonna be high drama I think
in LA this year well you also had the
Lonzo ball situation where the
information his medical information was
leaked to the media therefore you can't
trade somebody who is injured and do you
think that's the like the game plan
there that maybe somebody said look
there's a possibility you could be
traded for Kawhi Leonard let's put this
information out there and you won't be
traded you believe that I think that was
part of it
put it this way I don't believe it came
from the Lakers at all and I think that
might have been part of it but I saw him
Lonzo the last thing I'm scared I was
being traded to San Antonio because San
Antonio wants nothing to do with him you
know and not just him they don't wanted
to do with the circus that comes with
him
that's just not a Spurs way to go long
ago still has some some value and his
where his teams are bringing the Lavar
circus you know with him they'll acquire
him but it's more you know small market
teams with nothing to lose that that
don't have the established culture of a
San Antonio so I I I think that what
you're saying is right you know you put
the surgery thing out there to make it
avoid a trade but in the case of San
Antonio I'm fairly certain it wasn't
necessary well okay now we still don't
know where Melo is gone and this Kawai
gonna be dealt this year so update his
hobby I'd be surprised in I'd be
surprised that Bello doesn't wind up at
Houston the way the waste and into other
what no sentence the way Oklahoma City
is operating now is it's trying to find
a trade partner here to make it more
financially palatable now that this
trade partner is is not going to keep
Carmelo Anthony what what the trade
partners trying to do is basically take
on Carmela's contract they'd waive him
for Oklahoma City but in exchange they'd
get you know a couple of second-round
picks or something of value back in
return Oklahoma City for what I
told a few days ago is still no kind of
sitting through those offers but
eventually it's going to end with
Carmelo there and you know while Miami's
in the mix and in Pat Riley you know is
always in kind of talent acquisition
mode always try to find you know guys
that could help him win right away
Houston just makes way too much sense
the Rockets have recruited him in the
past Carmelo is comfortable with that
front office Chris Paul is there I don't
know how it works and and I think the
Rockets will take a significant step
back defensively if they bring in
Carmelo Anthony but I think the Rockets
are in a strong frontrunner position
right now and not the Lakers no I think
it's it's almost like the Lakers would
probably go after Carmelo if if Ron told
them to it's almost like it was with
Dwyane Wade you know a year ago in
Cleveland I don't think they they want
him where is Houston you know they want
him you know what do you you think it's
right or not or the Rockets are better
or not
the Rockets Daryl Morey they want him
and that means something to come out
like the money is gonna wind up being a
factor any of this probably gonna be the
minimum which he should be fine with
because of the money is gonna get in
that bio from Oklahoma City but III
think that the Rockets wanting him is a
big factor that and Kawhi Leonard has
been kind of quiet here yeah it's you
know when you talk to people in Vegas
it's really quiet I mean there are still
teams talking to San Antonio
I wouldn't say regularly but checking in
periodically and I think I told you this
before Dan that there are teams that
think that they could put together an
offer right now
with guys on their rosters that would
would make a deal with San Antonio get
done but those are teams that have no
idea what Kawhi is thinking long-term
and and also have no idea what his
medical situation is which is equally
significant so we're kind of at a
standstill here and I think we're going
to be at this point until the Lakers
decide to re-engage here if they don't
I'm not sure what happens but I think
the Spurs are back in the Lakers
re-engaging and trying to get something
done there yeah I'm trying to figure
this out from San Antonio's perspective
if you know that he wants to play for
the Lakers you know he doesn't want to
stay there
why not trade him to the Lakers where
you know you can get the most out of
that
as opposed to sending him to Toronto or
Philadelphia well I mean it if your San
Antonio you just want the best offer on
the table I mean you don't care whatever
happens to Kauai after that is his
problems in the Lakers problem and then
certainly not yours I think there is
there is a sentiment in San Antonio that
if they drag this thing out you know
maybe Toronto gets antsy and offers
something up big Masai Ujiri as we know
has been looking to shake up that roster
this offseason you know Philadelphia we
know they've got that hold there at
small forward Bret Brown or whoever the
wins of running that's another big
questions gonna want if there's a real
GM out there could they get antsy I
looked at their is there I'll say this
about the the Laker connection with
Kauai teams aren't necessarily terrified
of that I mean a good team with with a
strong foundation there is a sense they
could convince guilin to stay there's
not this overwhelming sense that Kawhi
Leonard is is guaranteed to be earmarked
for LA in the following summer there's
this teams right now that are kind of
weighing risk/reward
and nobody is really in that much of a
rush as we're sitting here in mid-july
is this the final Laker roster is this
what they're gonna open up the season
with in your opinion I think so maybe a
couple of tweaks you're there and look
the quiet thing obviously stands as as
the thing that could shake it up but you
know when when you talk to people around
that team they seem pretty comfortable
with with what they have here they like
what they've gotten from some of their
younger guys at Summer League don't get
minutes in the regular season and and
look out I mean I don't know I don't
know what to see like the idea not to
rehash old territory with you Dan but
the idea that putting non shooters
around LeBron is gonna work still still
perplexes me I don't know how that's
gonna work where you try to turn LeBron
James into a modern-day version of
chrome alone and playing on the low post
and and have guys around and play make
in ways that they've never done around
LeBron before I think it's gonna be
challenging to say the least to
construct an office that looks like that
over/under 50 wins with the Lakers you
going over under I'm going under I'm
gonna say 45 to 47 and it'll put him in
the fight for the playoffs it took about
47 last year to get in West is tough
again it's going to take some time to
gel as
you know that even if they do wind up
working I'm gonna say 45 wins at the
low-end 47 of the high so Seaton were we
rolling on that with what Mannix
Anderson yeah we got it okay all right
hey thank you see tonight I probably
preciate that you have any of my good
takes there do you have anything yeah
yeah we have that call you made man that
yeah it's pain you had Ricky Rubio Dante
Exum know anybody else in there that
your doctor did get a three-year 33
million dollar contract everybody
everybody gets a big contract now yes
McLovin no they don't Dante Exum was a
restricted for agent you know Susan's up
like Marcus smart looking for a job
Rodney hood still looking for a job who
would you rather only the Dante Exum or
Marcus smart stop it stop Dan got an
offer for 11 million dollar jazz this
off - yes yeah they need a point guard
there Utah no no Dan of the CED try to
steal my Thunder there no he you would
have averaged six seven points because
Ricky Rubio would have set you up clean
beyond the three-point line okay enjoy
your hair for the next couple of weeks
we'll see you at the end of the month
hi Dan all right that's Chris Mannix
Yahoo Sports for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]